debate club evidently a fan of you too
he knew what you're up to this weekend
hey guys it's nick from bum [ __ ]
tennessee
got a debate club for you heard you guys
were having on tim dillon
and then his little war he's got going
on with airbnb correct
so the debate you stick with those
airbnbs with those
nice clean hit us when you go to those
motel sticks that's where all them lot
lizards are
yeah i am having a thing
what's going on i'm having a war with
two lesbians uh that have an airbnb and
joshua tree
who raided me poorly breaking a cactus
how do i even do that you sloppy [ __ ]
what are you talking about you goofy
[ __ ] how do i even break a [ __ ]
cactus okay the
the the literal furniture was like art
pieces no one could sit in it
they were like [ __ ] chairs without
backs how long were you there
one night one night i brought a few
friends out there got a good deal on it
got it for less than half of what it
usually rents for because
last minute oh gotcha because we're just
out in palm springs it's too cold i'm
like let's all go to joshua tree
and uh we went out there i had my
producer with me i had
another guy who podcast with me and then
i think if you go on my story you might
be able to still see these [ __ ]
chairs that they had it was like to a
point
so like how did just to for their
defense how uh
how did the cactus get broke no one
touched it this is the thing
the cactus was like falling apart yeah i
probably don't have it on my yeah
i don't have it but the reality is these
chairs were like literally
so like have you ever seen chairs where
you're like no one can sit on them those
weren't them
no one can sit on these [ __ ] chairs
and
uh i have one here i have a photo of one
here i'll just i'll just give it to you
right now but just to give you an idea
of how bad it was so did they tell you
nothing
look at that oh you don't want to sit on
them they look horrible look at that
oh they're terrible so i mean this this
[ __ ] [ __ ] like wrote this whole
thing where she was like
he was a bad guest he clogged the
toilets he broke our chairs nobody broke
anything the chairs were like
the chairs were like weird chairs that
you like we went up to them they were
like falling apart
like you put them together and we just
left a few dishes in the sink and that
was it did you have a rager though
no we did four people just had a dinner
nobody had a rager
so i threatened uh her on her text
i said um well now i know where where
your house is now hopefully nothing
happens to it
that's what you said yeah she said i was
stupid and then she goes
are you threatening me i'm like lol
we'll see what happens and then i sent
her a gif of the simpsons house burning
you know the simpsons house the burns
that gift i sent that to her and she's
like
okay bro and then i just trashed her on
my podcast
because she's being a [ __ ] and her and
her wife are horrible people is she
older
her name's like mila jonah and mila yeah
they have these dumb like they're posing
with a dog in their airbnb photo
whatever they're like we worked our
whole lives in this house like
shut the [ __ ] up shut up so and i gave
them a great review because i'm not a
rat and i don't hurt people's business
so i was like a beautiful place
i never you know give somebody a bad
review never
i don't yelp i don't comment uber i
don't know uber no
i don't do any of that i have spit on an
uber driver
we've gotten a physical fight where i
kicked the back of his chair
and he he spit at me and i spit back at
him because he wouldn't take me through
the drive-through taco bell
i still rated him highly you understand
i
still rated him because up until our
fight
he did fine yeah he's cool he did a good
job he cut through traffic you were
trying to get a job
were you trying to get a double decker i
was trying to get a a cheesy a gordita
crunch
oh yeah i said let's just go through the
drive-through and he said no and he
started screaming at me
so i just started kicking his seat like
kicking the back of a seat then he spit
on me i
spit on him and then i had to get out of
the car but uber kicked me
uber kicked me off for like six months
but now i'm back
i'm back and that's cool i had the
opposite happen i was
i drove for uber and i this lesbian
couple was in the back and it was bar
time and this was back in the day when
surge was huge it'd be five times ten
times
yeah make two two hundred dollars one
ride and they asked to go through an
in-n-out
drive-through and i was like no i'm
sorry i can't do that
and they got super pissed and they're
like drop us off here and they smash my
window and they stole all the waters on
my back of my car
but here's the deal man why are you not
making them happy
uh because time is time is money at that
point get out of my car it's an equal
transaction like i don't i'm an
independent truck contractor did you not
like did you did you not want to get a
[ __ ] double double
yeah animal stuff [ __ ] bro not a half
hour later i didn't
oh wow dude you're gonna get money right
because the lesbians and some spread
that could have been a [ __ ] real
story there's two ways to really make
money on uber it's distance
traveled and number of rides sitting
idle you're not gonna make your money
wow
understood hey didn't know that did they
leave you a bad review
oh yeah but i i called uber immediately
because i knew it was going to be an
issue
and so like you got to get out right now
i don't need bad reviews so listen this
year
like i had a bad airbnb in uh palm beach
my brother booked it was a real
[ __ ] yeah this air the pictures look
dope dude so airbnb [ __ ]
literally texted me this morning
threatening yoona would you like me to
see if i can get that review removed and
i wrote yes so i think it worked
and i think people went to her and said
this guy's having a lot of fun with your
house
he's making a mockery of it yeah as it
deserves to be made a mockery
it's not gonna cause it is ridiculous
and it's not no it will not stop i will
have
fans of mine rent the airbnb and i will
go in it and just go crazy
and be like [ __ ] i'll never leave your
home i'll live in your [ __ ] house
you're gonna squat
i'll squat there i'll do whatever and
she got mad because we made like burgers
and like baked beans and like
other campfire foods yeah they sound
like real
[ __ ] don't get mad at me i left i left
a few dishes in the sink she's like the
cleaning crew complained i'm like about
what cleaning
yeah that's their [ __ ] i paid a 400
cleaning fee [ __ ]
do it yeah we never leave here's what i
would say i love airbnbs i will still go
probably airbnb over hotels in most
situations
hey because like when i was on the road
to a comedy i brought my opener with me
and when we were it's an air
if i get a hotel i want a nice hotel so
if i gotta get him a room in the mia
room
it's a lot of money tonight we don't get
a yard we don't get this we don't get
that
with an airbnb we each have our own room
we have rooms to spare and sometimes we
have a pool we have a yard
we have a way more comforting area tv
yeah it's much more comfortable man
all day i don't do hotels at all anymore
especially during covet i mean but i'll
go to like the rich carlton in naples
there's certain hotels i like sure
certain hotels i like see
blueberry pancakes on a beach hauler
on the beach i would still rather do
airbnb even over a nice hotel because
you can get a dope here you see that the
difference
is this is the one difference and now
because the coveted hotel's the one
difference that hotels are not bringing
to the table right now and it is like a
room service
so it's like there's something nice
about being like hey i'm
i i'm in a hotel i walk right to the
beach i sit on my chair
where's my drinks where's my food that's
the reality that's the only thing i
don't even drink but like
just you know even to just be like hey
man i'm [ __ ] hot can you get me a
bottle of water can you give me some
give me a mozzarella stick and they do
it and you tip them and that's a nice
transaction
but for sure not [ __ ] a motel 6 over
airbnb
no that young man was asking no that
young man is
figuring out what is the best place to
do math with his mother yeah he was like
i like to like
like crystal with my parents where can
we do that and it's like i don't know
dude
no good decisions have come out of motel
6 100 i used to do cocaine in motels
never a motel six not that bad but uh
and and uh they were fun rooms to just
because you had wind protection are you
completely
uh sober now 100 no drinks 10 years
oh wow wow no no uh temptation at all
no i mean can you be around it
occasionally the one thing that i do is
like i have occasional slip up like
occasionally i'll do heroin
occasionally i'll show like i shoot
heroin i'll shoot up but that's
it no okay occasionally i'll have a
cigarette that's the baddest thing i do
that's not bad it's not great
are you tempted though like when you go
to a comedy club there's alcohol
everywhere never
because i'm over it it's you're tempted
for the first two or three years then
you're over and i'm like i'm just over
it
yeah yeah that makes sense so airbnb it
[Music]
is
[Music]
is